[Music]
have you guys heard of Aldi yeah the
grocery store
oh she kinda shook up oh that's although
they're not they're not around here but
their shoe stores where it would mingle
was some in a city yeah I grew up with
all did like they were always in the
Midwest Oh moving out to California no
you guys ever been to a Piggly wigglies
no yeah that's a grocery store is it
really sounds nudists [ __ ] I've ever
been to a ding ha Bing hell okay good
sandwiches yeah all these UK division
this is for the UK division they came up
with this campaign to demonstrate the
spirits of in it together Ness
so they came up with this whole
challenge that they signed this
influencer up for where they were
challenging her to feed her family for a
week on twenty five British pounds which
is about 33 US dollars of groceries and
they chose the hashtag Aldi poorest day
challenge why would they do what oh my
because they're saying that people tend
to spend too much money over the
holidays and through legal challenge
he's a different word broke-ass
challenge a lot of people need to
tighten their budgets in the month of
January and so they wanted this campaign
to demonstrate like how you know people
can still feed their family by shopping
at Aldi through the poorest day of the
year until payday and so they signed up
choses hashtag the influence you know 35
people at a [ __ ] marketing firm of
dumb [ __ ] who know nothing
that's what blows my making of 150,000
my mind at these marketing agencies
these guys all go to school yeah they do
this [ __ ] and they come out with dumb
ass [ __ ] things like this problem
though they go to [ __ ] they go to
some College get some degree for this
[ __ ] and they have no idea how to
[ __ ] market anything going to college
for marketing is not the same as an
understanding marketing like like every
[ __ ] I've seen so many washout
youtubers become some social media
[ __ ] marketing person and I'm like
you never
even built an audience on YouTube you
don't know how the [ __ ] to do it but
that's who gets hired by these companies
because really I'm bullshitting right
now and I built the [ __ ] audience of
nobody cares one of those there's so
many of them you have no idea it would
make you cringe and throw up at the same
time these people are clearing
six-figure salaries at some company
having never built a YouTube audience
and just wiping out of the medium it's
nuts
so they recruited this fashion
influencer named Natalie Lee who has
this blog and so she joined the
challenge and so this is her post what
the photo looks like - here would you
like to read the caption sure Aldi has
challenged me to feed my family of four
Jesus for a whole week breakfast lunch
and dinner for 25 pounds to see if it's
possible 25 pounds for a whole week
possible as possible J where J is
probably the hardest month of the year
financially for most people so I'm
interested to see if I could feed my
family with a well balanced and
nutritious week's worth I mean
nutritious week's food shop what do you
think follow along on my stories to see
how I get on family of four what with
like 35 lots of rice and beans and you
can do scary yep with marinara
the most expensive thing will be like
Frazee yeah meat and in produce this
post also had originally the hashtag I
mentioned and so immediately she just
got it started getting a whole but like
the first comment that you kind of see
here it says totally just tasteful and
completely out of touch what's worse are
the disingenuous replies to comments so
those and support thinks it's a great
challenge into those Chris's I can't
read the rest but people were so upset
they're like what the [ __ ] like my meat
like I am poor like I do have to do this
on a daily I'm not some [ __ ]
challenge like how out of touch are you
from reality this is insane but what if
she gets some pretty good strategy that
that person he'd be like oh [ __ ] ever
thought of that well what have they
actually got a poor influencer to do it
that would have been better well it's
tough right because I
okay so I watched this teacher channel I
like this guy his name's a wolf pit and
he always reviews frozen food and he's
like I can't believe this sucks every
time sounds familiar
yeah I think but he does this thing now
where he tries to make a very low-cost
meal for families who are struggling and
so he's like yo I made this whole dish
for like $5 a day 85 cents that can feed
you for a [ __ ] week or whatever it's
always like the carbs and stars isn't
[ __ ] that's time you could look at that
and go like wait like he's making money
off of the links and people like who are
poor who were gonna watch this in turn
make the recipes like it gets really
cynical after a certain amount like
where you can just like what they're
saying is like yo you can have like be
cheap about shopping for [ __ ] you want
to just buy [ __ ] [ __ ] because how
many people just throw a [ __ ] package
in Jarell in their car and they don't
need it that's what I was taking from it
I think it's more about the attitude
like there is a way Italy yeah that's uh
my zit is so bad it's maybe the
terminology definitely determine a
florist
that's where they [ __ ] the hardest
because people that's all that people
were latching onto to they're like poor
the [ __ ] like they said on there was
this other one they live poor on a daily
basis that this isn't a trend for them
living on 25 pounds is a reality to 8.4
million working adults in this country I
don't think they're saying it's a trend
though I think that they're really
legitimately trying to try it out I get
it tact wise I understand but dude it's
like understanding people's intentions
is so important right I don't know cuz
the pillows maybe hashtag best bang for
the buck challenge or some other
challenge literally anyway like I said a
dumb [ __ ] marketing firm company for
sure but the intention I totally think
is though this other one told BuzzFeed
because the article I have would be
BuzzFeed [ __ ] sensitive as [ __ ]
they said all they have basically just
offended their entire customer base
their demographic isn't middle-class
professionals it's the poor so what
they're saying is that this challenge
was for the middle class and upper
that's like hey guys let's let's try to
be like poor people
one week well this is the rest of her
quote so then she says it suggests poor
people aren't trying hard enough to
budget they can get all the groceries
they will ever need from Aldi for 25
pounds so what are they moaning for it
perpetuates the myth that poor people
aren't trying hard enough
that's no it's just a [ __ ] it's just
a helper thing dude look I get it
they're not trying to go you're poor
people you're not trying hard enough
holy [ __ ] how cynical you have to be I
didn't buy me that I took it as like hey
guys let's try to save money I was like
wow a grocery store that's trying to get
you to save money that's [ __ ] crazy
because they want to spend more it was a
youtuber what I saw was them going like
hey did you ever consider us because
we're pretty reasonably priced there's a
youtuber who just camped outside in a
u-haul in negative 30 [ __ ] degree
weather and like Minnesota some [ __ ] and
he got like you all said like yo [ __ ]
you don't use our [ __ ] anymore but like
you could easily say like yo there were
people who are actually [ __ ] homeless
and like who live in vans and like
you're just like exploring that but
meanwhile you have a million subs on
YouTube but it's like he's just like
[ __ ] showing people like how crazy
this [ __ ] is and like how hard it is and
like how much this sucks like if
anything it's not it's not a
glorification people are [ __ ] cynical
man damn and I say that as a cynical
person this other image that they
included with someone's IG post so
there's like screenshot which looks like
it's from Wikipedia and it's about
poverty porn also known as development
porn famine porn or stereotyped porn has
been defined as any type of media the
ridet written photographed or filmed
which exploits the poor's forest
condition in order to generate the
necessary sympathy for selling
newspapers or increasing charitable
donations or support for a given cause
it also suggests that the viewer of the
exploited protagonist is motivated by
gratification of base instincts it's
also a term of criticism applied to
films which objectify people in poverty
for the sake of entertaining a
privileged audience
so what's Extreme Couponing then because
that's how I see this every time I see
how to [ __ ] get a deal I'm like oh
that's frugal I think that's just being
frugal I know a billionaire that loves
discounts
who doesn't he's a billionaire bro so
hey really my spending all their money
can't wait for a discount on camera
equipment he's like oh my god I got this
lens for 30% off and I'm like what the
[ __ ] you have all the money in the world
doesn't matter but for them it's like
it's a game it's like some people love
saving money because it's a challenge if
you want to go there dude I just saw
some [ __ ] dissertation video on
YouTube where a guy talks about why
Horrible Bosses is is [ __ ] up the
movie Horrible Bosses is [ __ ] oh my god
because in the movie Jennifer Aniston is
sexually assaulting Charlie Day yep and
I'm like that's what's funny about it
is that she's hotter than [ __ ] and he's
saying no that's all that's all and my
god right the irony of that and people
are like this is [ __ ] up there's so
many double standards on [ __ ] like if a
guy did that all the [ __ ] and I'm like
dude know what the inclination is is
that guys are more down usually the [ __ ]
usually not all the time right now and
yes guys get raped and all this other
stuff
I know that's not what the movies
talking about guys don't get raped it
doesn't matter what if the hottest woman
one of the hottest women on earth even
at [ __ ] 45 50 was trying to suck your
dick and you're like no thanks I'm a
doctor like that's all that's the laughs
like that's why people are laughing but
if you want to go there and talk about
how horrible everything is and like oh I
think so heavy
everything's so heavy I think you can
find a problem with anything somebody
charged that's true that's what I'm
saying yeah like you have to just make
sure that what you're trying to get
across has the right tone cuz I feel I
feel like there's a way to say any and
everything absolutely I was like happy
new year what the [ __ ] do you mean do I
not look happy or like hey I heard you
guys talking about Jackie news about
poor people and about how people are
hungry what kind of car do you drive
do you really need that car to drive
like I do I'm not even getting like [ __ ]
like that this is where all this yeah
pull from something anything to just
[ __ ] take a [ __ ] on you so that
you're the one who's [ __ ] on now for
talking about it and that's Rob you
can't be you can't be giving ya can't
discuss a topic you can't even do a
challenge anymore yes
by the way 20 to 5 that's how much my
car was 20 to 5
and I got I got two and a half off of it
because I told my truck
I even owe my car [ __ ] there you go
leasing I leased that [ __ ] which is the
smart thing to do if you're gonna get
luxury always least never buy because it
depreciates depreciation I'm gonna get
bored of it in three years and hey
anyway and it's a hundred percent right
off
that's 100% genuine leather up oh yeah
and it's got seat warmers Oh when I'm
driving and I'm thinking about poverty I
like to keep my ass warm
[Music]